le chesnay-versailles arraché son ticket
pour remonter dès cette année en
nationale 2 ce dimanche les filles de
vinko bardy qui ont dominé escaudain sur
leur terrain 65 à 56 lors du dernier
match des playoffs devant plus d'une
centaine de supporters après 9 à 0 dans
les premières secondes du lcv a fait la
course en tête pendant toute la partie
avec un écart de plus 10 à la fin du
troisième quart temps
on mérite de gagner pas seulement ce
match là
e
on mérite
de monter parce que cette année on avait
que deux de fait je pense que ce soit on
sait toutes mobilisées au match aller on
n'était pas présente on a on a manqué
beaucoup de choses et on ne sait pas
combative
ce soir on voulait vraiment la victoire
et on s'est battus premier de la saison
régulière avec une seule défaite le
chesnay-versailles termine également sur
la première marche du podium des
playoffs les yvelinoises affiche donc un
bilan de seulement 2 défaites en 26
matches disputés cette saison très très
très belle équipe on était fort mais
c'est toujours très vite bien
d'affronter donc remonter parce que on a
travaillé très dur il faut montrer trop
tout ça sur le terrain
notre force c'est l'équipe c'est
vraiment l'équipe parce que on à se
trouver
restez soudés entre eux c'est un peu
difficile et c'est ce qui fait qu'on
gagne ce soir
un état d'esprit que l'équipe devra
garder pour espérer se maintenir la
saison prochaine en nationale 2
l'objectif annoncé par le club